dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean IFA here this is
going to be absolutely amazing earlier
we had some delightful discussions on
synthesizing sound from animations the
input would be a sequence for instance a
video depicting the complete and utter
destruction of plates wooden bunnies or
footage of bubbling water and the output
should be a physical simulation that
yields appropriate sound effects for the
observed phenomenon in short input
animation output synthesized sound
effects for this animation and get this
what if we will turn the problem around
where we have sound as an input and we
try to synthesize an animation that
could create such a sound hmm I like it
very spicy project indeed and however
crazy the idea may sound given the
richness sound effects in nature it may
actually be easier to generate a
believable animation than a perfect
sound effect it is extremely difficult
to be able to match the amazingly
detailed real-world sound of for
instance a sliding rolling or bouncing
bolt with a simulation the more I think
about this the more I realize that this
direction actually makes perfect sense
and no machine learning is used here if
we look under the hood we'll see a pre
generated database of rigidbody
simulations with dozens of different
objects and a big graph that tries to
group different events and motions
together and encode the order of
execution of these events and motions
now hold on to your papers and let's
check out the first round of results
together
you
Wow I think it would be an
understatement to say that they nailed
it and what's more we can also add
additional constraints like a prescribed
landing location to the object to make
sure that the animations are not too
arbitrary but are more in line with our
artistic vision crazy as I'm looking
through the results I am still in
complete disbelief this shouldn't be
possible also please don't get the
impression that this is all there is to
this technique there are a lot more
important details that we haven't
discussed here that the more curious
fellow scholars could be interested in
discrete and continuous time contact
events time warping and motion
connections there are tons of goodies
like these in the paper please have a
look to be able to better gauge and
appreciate the merits of this work some
limitations apply such as the
environment is constrained to be this
plain that we have seen in these
animations and as always with works that
are inventing something completely new
it currently takes several minutes which
is not too bad but of course there is
plenty of room to accelerate the
execution times and some bonus footage
blue dice are synchronized with hi-hat
hits and the red dice are synchronized
with the bass and snare
this will be just spectacular for
creating music videos animated movies
and I'm convinced that professional
artists will be able to do incredible
things with such a tool thanks for
watching and for your generous support
I'll see you next time